all right
i get the same guy again
okay some people are just plain
ridiculous well what can you say he's
20 points lower something and then
immediately offers a draw
well it last game i just donated him the
full point
was blundering d4 for nothing
so
yeah we transposed into a symmetrical
english
position
i should have considered at least taking
on g5
okay this position is completely okay
for me but
at least i should have invested a couple
of seconds to
to check this possibility
okay so we got the pretty
standard position here
okay wants to exchange this as well
okay yeah the only thing
i always need to be conscious of is
the idea of bishop h3 at some point
this could be a problem that he controls
c8 and i cannot easily
play on the c file
um
okay figures okay
i can play this now first
on bishop h3 i can also just play rook
c7
it's not not
not a great move
what about f5 f5 then e4 maybe
i have rook c2
yeah i don't want to play so passive
with rook c7
of course e4 yeah but f rook c2 maybe
knight e5
knight f6
i should have done some more calculation
about this maybe but
well the time situation
all right um maybe this is just this one
attacking d5
okay this should just be should just be
equal
or round equal okay it's got two bishops
but
that's a compact position here for black
so you're just trying to exchange this
here to get a completely
boring boring position maybe
could be but well it's um it's fine for
black
it's um it's not equal actually i'm a
bit better here
yeah okay this is this can be played
for a win with no risk at all but like
i have the queen side completely frozen
and the only potential idea here is
some somewhere to play f4
and maybe expose f2 as a weakness
so um
i'll try to to pile up here okay he
prevented this but maybe e3 now is
a weakness
idea could be um to play e5
and pile up on e3
of course i need to be cautious because
any move by the e pawn would
of course um awake um
awaken this bishop which is a sorry
piece at the moment
okay
yeah okay i could play e5
and you then would need to cover
everything
just just passively
maybe i need to need to play b5 as well
i'll show the straightforward plan
attacking e3
might might not be um
enough to really get something
of course um i need to be um
i need to stay modest here it's not um
it's not um likely that um
black has a clear advantage or something
you cannot expect to
to to win here quickly okay what what
about b3 now
okay i know but not i could take it at
e3 hanging on
this
and it's not just the pawn it's also
a huge discovery let's take here
takes rook e3 king f2
okay
time warning play somewhat quicker
you will always have this issue here on
e3
it's still not um
not easy to win
yeah i overlooked your phone but i don't
think it's
so um okay
for attention check
i took a a g5 would have been possible
i could i could just take f5 okay then i
should really capture here
stupid
should have taken immediately
so also matter of time now
yeah okay this is just a draw draw
offered
draw offered he's playing this on time
great
i immediately knew this guy is just an
[ __ ] sorry but
this early draw offers are just terrible
yeah this is a repetition of 50 move
rule or something
okay this one goes on the list for the
next games
yeah okay maybe i should have um should
have won this
also a bit um a bit of a time issue
again
yeah very nervous and strange game
somehow didn't really take g4 into
account
maybe i need to to take first on f4
yeah hard to tell okay